so i am loving fill them boots such a
great song but i also love
summer job money it has such a great
vibe what inspired that song
um honestly great question i'm a huge
kenny chesney fan
uh i love summertime nostalgic throwback
kind of songs and he's the king of those
and i have been trying and trying and
trying to uh
write this kind of song for so long and
i feel like this song summer job money
does
exactly uh what i want it to do it's a
summertime nostalgic
uh throwback and i cannot wait for
people to hear it can't wait to play it
live as well
oh they that oh me and that would just
be so exciting i i can only imagine how
much everyone just wants to get back out
there play live
it's the kind of song you put in the car
and you play it over and over again like
if you're on a long drive like
it's that kind of song for me yeah well
hey spread that rumor
[Laughter]
um now i have to ask what is the worst
summer job
you've ever had well i only had one
summer job and a lot of people don't
know this story
but um i've only had one summer job and
that was working landscaping for my
dad's business laying in sun's landscape
and that he still runs to this day
and one that i did all the way
up until i signed a record deal here in
nashville i was still doing landscaping
on the side
wow that's amazing so when did you start
doing it what age were you when you
started doing landscaping with your dad
i was 14 um something like that yeah
and uh my parents always were like you
know what
uh if you want to at the time you know i
don't even know if abercrombie is still
a thing this is
kind of funny that i didn't even bring
this up but back in the day
when i was in high or middle school in
high school like
everybody always wanted abercrombie
clothes and my parents always said well
guess what
if you want to spend that much money on
clothes you're gonna have to have a job
and you can
buy whatever you want with that and so
my brother-in-law both we'd get out
there and
help my dad every summer when we were uh
out of school and then i you know i went
to college every summer i'd come home
i'd work and save up money and then when
i graduated college i just kind of
full-on jumped into that until i could
figure out exactly what i wanted to do
and
hallelujah i i've you know
landed a gig playing music yeah
i love that you wanted a summer job so
you could afford abercrombie clothes
they were expensive back then
they were expensive expensive
that's so great okay so obviously i'm
assuming you're making a little bit more
money now as a performer so i want to
know
when you first got that big paycheck
like a life-changing paycheck
what was the first big purchase you made
i think a truck um which i still have to
this day
um it was just a a gmc denali truck that
i really loved a lot and and
one that i always wanted could never
afford and i
just kind of jumped out there did that
now my first uh
the first thing that i bought when i
moved into this house that lauren and i
are in
right now um is a putting green for my
backyard
that's awesome i get golf is my thing
like
when i'm not on the road and i'm not
playing music that is what i love the
most so any chance i can get out here
and practice that's why i threw that
green out there oh that's so
cool that's a dream come true back here
yeah thank you
yeah well speaking of lauren i'm going
to say your most important summer job is
going to be being a father
congratulations how are you feeling
thank you so much yeah we're incredibly
excited
uh nervous at the same time you know i
have an identical twin brother and he
has
a son that i've been able to play uncle
to you know for
10 years now he's 10 years old and um
while i'm nervous my brother tells me
hey hey yeah
you're going to be a little tired in the
beginning but um
what you should expect is you you're not
going to understand a love
uh you've never known a love like you're
going to know uh when that baby comes
out so i'm excited for that
um you know lauren and i tried for a
while and and uh
the silver lining in this whole pandemic
situation is it actually gave
us a chance to i wasn't exhausted from
coming in off the road or
whatever it may be it gave us time to
actually
work on that and and i cannot wait to
meet him that's so i'm so excited for
you so on a scale of one to ten how
ready are you like you have the nursery
do you have everything prepared
i'm sitting in the nursery that is not
prepared but i i did
get away from the dogs because the dogs
think that no one's allowed to walk on
the street in front of our house they
would just howl how how at the front
window
so i was like where can i go this kind
of quiet that they won't bark
um here in the nursery now it's not
finished i actually just put this
uh crib together the other day um
but lauren's gonna try to finish it up
in the next couple weeks because the
baby's gonna be here into may
yeah that is so exciting and you said
you're having a baby boy right
yeah baby boy i prayed so hard for a boy
lauren wants a girl as well so
i'm gonna pray hard for a girl the
second time around oh yeah
but you got your boy i wanted a boy
because
hey i want to make him a pga tour star
that is my thing i will i'm gonna
i'm gonna work this out you got the
backyard for it
that's so exciting um has she sent you
out on any late night cravings runs
yeah i feel like that happens a lot you
in the beginning
um in the beginning a lot of times she
wanted pickles which
yeah super weird i've heard a lot of
people really like that when
it's a thing yeah the other thing she
sends me out for a lot
are uh are the
mcflurries from mcdonald's oh those are
amazing
but the mcdonald's that i go to i swear
they say their ice cream machine is
broke every time i go there and i got
all the way across town to a different
one it's so annoying
oh aren't you a good partner i am i am
aw that's so exciting okay so you're
nervous how's your family doing are they
just like
jumping with joy yeah um a major
blessing is happening in our life right
now because
you know my family's in north carolina
yeah and uh we don't get to see them
that much
my parents don't like traveling um
they'll probably come up obviously when
we have the baby but
they don't they don't love traveling on
the other hand lauren's parents
love traveling and uh
they just bought the house three doors
down from us and that is going to be the
biggest blessing
of my entire life that is so
amazing was that their idea yeah so
um obviously they'll spend a lot of time
here uh
you know as first-time grandparents
of course uh yeah for
they always welcome stay at our house
but for whatever reason they decided
uh a house up the street um
became free to buy and and they decided
to do that and they're gonna
uh build their own little house right
down the road from us
that's amazing you're gonna have
built-in babysitters just on the street
i know and then yeah my dad and uh or
i'm sorry
myself and her dad you know he's a big
time golfer as well so so it'll give me
a chance to
have someone to always go out and play
golf with as well
i love that well i know that you're
working on a new album you've got new
music coming out
is what's going on in your life right
now going to influence this next chapter
of music for you
yeah i think um sorry my dogs are going
crazy in there oh it's okay
yeah i think i have a whole new set of
inspirations that's for sure when i go
into a writing room not every song
about you know those life things but
um yeah i i definitely think it will
have some influence on
uh my writing moving forward i've even
sat down and tried to write my son a
song
just have it just for fun and um i feel
like it turned out all right i'm
thinking about recording it and maybe
just having it for him to to uh
you know when he's old enough to
understand
so so yeah i'd say it has influenced um
a little bit of my writing already yeah
oh i love that
so much okay so um with this new album
is there a certain word you can
attach to it for kind of the vibe that
you're going with
yeah well great question so i forgot to
hit on this
and and the last thing you asked me
there um so i'm actually not putting out
an album right now i am going to take a
much different approach than i've ever
taken in my entire career
and i'm going to put out one song at a
time
you know in the world of streaming
and social media everybody has
everything at the click of
their hand and and you know i feel like
people are so used to swiping up and
just
looking so fast that everything you know
with all the social media and all of
this stuff and so many artists putting
out music it's easy to get bored with
something very quickly or at least
i feel like a lot of people can um
so i feel like the approach of just
staying flexible and nimble when i write
a song that i love
it makes it much easier to just say well
i can get into the studio and record it
and put it out whenever i want opposed
to being tied down
to a 12-14 song project that could take
three years i mean it's been three years
since my last
uh record which is crazy to think about
and then almost two years since i
released big big clans so
yeah not being tied down to a record i
think is going to be a good approach for
me moving forward
that will eventually one day work itself
into
a record if you will yeah no that makes
sense to me and it keeps everything very
fresh too right
yeah yeah yeah but one i'm excited to
take
and do you think that will give you a
little bit more time to be a new dad
oh my gosh yes absolutely um it frees me
up a little bit
to uh to be there i i don't want to miss
a moment i know i'm super thankful for
my parents they were at
from when we were just kids all the way
through college you know i played
baseball in college and they were at
every single game and i want to make
sure that
i'm the same for uh my kids or right now
my son
um that i'm always there yeah
that's so exciting you don't have to
tell me if you don't want to but you
have a name picked out
we do um we aren't 100 percent
settled in on anything at this point but
we have narrowed it down to a couple
um which were you know pumped about
i did i've told a few people in
interviews this past week but
uh one of the names i threw out that got
shut down incredibly fast was
rambo rambo
no you can't do that in my mind i
thought
you know what that sounds tough so
whenever he comes up
uh on the tee box and they're saying you
know now on the t-box rambo lane it
sounds like he's 100 gonna hit the ball
400 yards
you know when you put it with your last
name it actually does sound kind of
badass
well it's not going to happen regardless
that's amazing uh well what a pleasure
getting to talk to you there's so much
exciting things going on in your life
right now congratulations on everything
i appreciate it thank you very much
thanks for taking
hey i'm graham o'neill for more on your
favorite country stars click subscribe
or watch the videos
over there